ambulanciers pompiers policiers
patrouilleurs les blessés ont vite été
prise en charge plusieurs ont été secoué
violemment dans les cabines
ça monte et ça descend des assiettes
côté ça vraiment brasser beaucoup j'ai
déjà tenté un avion qui brasse le stade
lat biel louis roy a eu peur sa
conjointe a d'ailleurs été blessé à un
oeil
pour ma part j'ai pensé que ça poyet la
pression souvent que ça rassure comme
c'est nerveux mais ça scan sous l'impact
au moins un skieur a été éjecté de la
cabine aussi mis à balancer de mort et
de l'eau dans notre presse que fait un
360 les vite
deux des trois vitre de la cabine ont
sont débarqués pas encore vraiment
partie de nous colocataires
on peut dire qu'ils ont été plus
explicites la cabine or td les pieds de
celui qui était quasiment complètement
l'extérieur de la gondole une chose qui
est resté quand même les services
d'urgences de beaupré ont demandé l'aide
des ambulanciers de québec
un autobus du rtc a aussi été dépêché
sur les lieux pour accueillir les
blessés légers
man au total on a 21 ans blessé une
douzaine de transport par ambulance et
par autobus du rtc neuf personnes on a
évacué la ligne de make annick mans en
reculant pour avoir une aire d'accueil
et platement à la base des gondoles avec
un médecin
la note a3 professionnels plus un
médecin c'est un arrêt d'urgence
inexpliqué qui a causé cette panne
brutale on est en mode inspection
enquête aussi de savoir un peu ce qui
s'est passé notre équipe d'entretien et
là dessus j'ai jamais vu une expérience
traumatisante pour les skieurs concernés
non ça fait plus jusqu'ici c'est la
première fois que ce type ce genre de
bris lors n'ont jamais vue sur le lagon
d'heure et commencé à descendre ont
passé on était comme rajaa temps on
savait pas trop ce qui est le cas des
cancers voler le takamaka taux plafond
qui est embarrassé et terriblement vous
eu le temps d'avoir peur
on pensait que ça pour moi le bout une
enquête de la régie du bâtiment du
québec est en cours
les registres d'inspection des
équipements seront vérifiés ici
ghislaine bûcher à radio-canada au mont
sainte anne